das selbsthilfezentrum machen hier
kümmern sich 450 beschäftigte um
menschen mit behinderung für alle
betreuer gilt vom sechzehnter märz an
die gesetzlichen pflicht die
geschäftsführer fürchten weitere
probleme bei der dienstplanung zwar sind
90 prozent des personals geimpft
trotzdem sind viele an corona erkrankt
oder wegen kontakten in quarantäne
deshalb fehlen uns die mitarbeiter an
allen ecken und enden jetzt schon und
wenn nach dem 16 märz ein
betretungsverbot ausgesprochen wurde
durch die gesundheitsbehörden dann
könnte das für uns bedeuten dass wir
unseren betrieb wirklich nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten können in ganz
deutschland herrscht personalmangel in
der pflege corona hat das verschärft
bestätigt der aachener
gesundheitsamtsleiter michael simons die
notfallstationen von sechs kliniken in
der städteregion aachen können schon
keine patienten mehr aufnehmen nicht
lebensbedrohliche notfälle müssen 30
kilometer weiter bis in die eifel
gefahren werden und noch mehr personal
not ruhe durch das gesetz für die teil
im pflicht den medizin und pflege das
gesetz des grottenschlecht weil es
einfach viel zu viele fragen ungeklärt
lässt zum beispiel schon die frage
dürfen wir ein betretungsverbot dem
arbeitgeber überhaupt mitteilen oder
welche nachweise müssen erbracht werden
was dürfen wir kontrollieren das wird
uns reihenweise vor gericht um die ohren
fliegen
trotzdem zum schutz kranker und alter
menschen sei die impfpflicht für
personal in kliniken und heimen
alternativlos
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
werden wir unbedingt brauchen denn in
den einrichtungen um die es hier geht
wird corona noch lange eine bedrohung
darstellen hier geht es um menschen die
sich selber nicht gut schützen können
deswegen müssen wir hier leib und leben
dieser leute schützen deswegen eignet
sich das nicht für parteipolitische
spielchen die drahtzieher der querdenker
bewegung warten ja nur darauf dass wir
uns hier nicht als handlungsfähig
erweisen deswegen haben wir hier eine
gemeinsame aufgabe zu bewältigen da
dürfen wir nicht zu hören diese
gemeinsame aufgabe wollten die parteien
der alten und neuen bundesregierung
meistern stimmten gemeinsam am 10
dezember im bundestag und danach im
bundesrat für die impfpflicht in der
pflege alles mit den stimmen der union
doch das gesetz ist schlecht gemacht
impfgegner fühlen sich bestärkt proteste
nehmen zu bundesweit drohen pflegekräfte
wegen ihrer impfpflicht mit kündigung
einer an den bundestag gerichtete
petition mit dem titel keine kopie
impfpflicht für das pflegepersonal bekam
ich nur wenigen wochen mehr als 120
tausend unterschriften
und auch insgesamt ändert sich die
stimmung lange gab es breite akzeptanz
für strenge corona regeln zu geplanten
impfpflicht mehr als 70 prozent
doch diese stimmung lässt stark nach in
einer umfrage zur berufsbezogenen
impfpflicht sind nur noch 46 prozent der
befragten dafür aber immerhin schon 41
prozent gegen die teile nicht den
medizin pflege und betreuung in wehnen
in der warnung der bevölkerung dass die
akzeptanz von verschärfungen von
maßnahmen zurück geht von jetzt ende
januar zu anfang februar jetzt findet
ein leichter stimmungsumschwung in der
bevölkerung statt ein stimmungsumschwung
zu beginn des jahres mit vier
landtagswahlen wichtig für die union
nach der niederlage im bund bayerns
ministerpräsident
söder versuchte stets sich in der korona
krise zu profilieren auch beim thema
impfpflicht für pflegekräfte
vor gut einem jahr löst söder die
debatte für die impfpflicht für pflege
aus jetzt stellt er das gesetz infrage
die einrichtungs gezogene impfpflicht
die zum 15 dritten kommen soll ist kein
wirksames mittel mehr um die jetzige
omikron welle zu begleiten oder zu
dämpfen oder zu stoppen sie kann aber
leider ein instrument sein um die
belastungssituation und pflegesituation
deutlich zu verschlechtern
so dass kehrtwende für den politologen
emanuel richter politisches kalkül das
ist ein politikstil der wirklich immer
nur polarisiert und der eigentlich
überhaupt gar nicht von programmatischen
überzeugungen gelenkt ist sondern immer
nur versucht gewissermaßen das fähnchen
in den wind zu hängen und mutmaßliche
wählerinnen und wähler willen
einzufangen und wiederzugeben ist keine
einheitliche linie erkennbar und das ist
dann auch für zu dem vorwurf dass es
eigentlich populistisch auf ist berlin
heute ist cdu chef friedrich merz auch
noch zum fraktionsvorsitzenden gewählt
worden dem neuen oppositionsführer kommt
die debatte um die impfpflicht gerade
recht er fordert für die gesamte union
die aussetzung des gesetzes
wir haben es hier also mit einer sehr
klaren sehr einheitlichen vollkommen
uneingeschränkten meinung der cdu und
der csu zu tun einschließlich der
fraktionsvorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidenten in dem von uns
geführten und den ländern in denen die
union verantwortung trägt also das sind
positionen die sich eigentlich mit dem
abstimmungsverhalten der parlamentarier
der cdu nicht übereinstimmen lassen
auch merz hat erst für die impfpflicht
in der pflege gestimmt jetzt kritisiert
er das gesetz schließlich ist wahlkampf
saarlands ministerpräsident tobias hans
will ende märz wiedergewählt werden auch
er hat die teil im pflicht mit
abgesegnet jetzt aber greift er den
politischen gegnern es macht keinen sinn
die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
jetzt zu vollziehen sie gehört
verschoben und wir erwarten von der
bundesregierung dass die offenen fragen
geklärt werden in nordrhein westfalen
muss sich ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst von der cdu im mai dem
wähler stellen auch er ist auf corona
schlingerkurs
den karnevalsauftakt am 11.11 hatte wüst
den großen massen genehmigt kurz darauf
verlangte er mehr kontrollen druck wir
dürfen keine halben sachen machen und
strafen seien der richtige weg
ende november ließ wüst landesregierung
ein vollbesetztes stadion zu beim
bundesliga-derby köln mönchengladbach
auf der tribüne feierten die fans dicht
an dicht viele ohne mundschutz von
seiner eigenen politik gab sich wüst
regelrecht geschockt
nicht wieder
derselbe zick zack kurs nun auch bei der
teil- impfpflicht erst stimmt wies dem
gesetz gemeinsam mit der bundesregierung
zu ob und wann sie umgesetzt wird das
lässt wüst auf nachfrage offen ähnlich
wankelmütig wie seine parteifreunde
herz und hand sie eben den wahlkampf
dazu nutzen die
politik instrumentalisieren und
eigentlich in gewisser weise auch die
bundes treue in frage stellen oder mit
auch die demokratie beschädigen wenn man
sich an die gesetze nicht hält die man
selbst mit beschlossen hat dann ist das
wirklich ein ganz fatales signal ich
sehe das wirklich auch als eine
bedrohung des demokratischen friedens
und insofern bin ich da schon sehr
erschrocken über die korona pandemie
geht ins dritte jahr und der union ist
inzwischen offenbar egal was sie gestern
noch für richtig hielt und sie hofft mit
diesem schlingerkurs wahlen zu gewinnen